hello friends welcome back my guest
today is Morgan Housel and that should
be a name that you're familiar with as I
published an episode with him only a
couple of weeks ago one of our top ever
played in modern wisdom history so why
is he back on I brought him back because
the current state of the financial
markets and the global economy is really
confusing I have no idea why the market
is 25% down and whether it's as bad as
the Great Depression from 1928 or the
financial crisis of 2008 or whatever it
is I needed someone who knows what he's
talking about
and Morgan is the man who has taken that
task on his shoulders so today expect to
learn just what is going on with the
financial markets why prices have
dropped just how this does compared to
previous financial crashes what some of
the signals would be that the market is
at least starting to calm down in terms
of volatility also at the very end of
this episode I give my best advice for
how to be anti fragile during this
situation if you are under containment
if you are potentially in lockdown or
there's some social distancing
procedures that you have to follow where
you can't leave the house as much stay
until the end to find out mine and
Morgan's best suggestions on how to not
only avoid boredom but perhaps even
flourish and develop yourself and your
family's lush home during the process in
other news I know that this is the
second in seven days of podcasts
regarding the corona virus I promise you
that this is not going to become the
kovat 19 podcast but I do think that as
someone with a platform and an audience
who is prepared to listen to long-form
in-depth discussions and also someone
who has access to the kind of guests
that I do there is a little bit of a
duty for me to try and provide the best
quality of information that I can the
episode with dr. Fagel ding from last
week which you should definitely go and
check out if you haven't already
teaching us about the virus and what it
actually does to the human body etc etc
it is the most-played
of all time
and I think that that is because people
are desperately searching for
information at the moment and if I can
in some way help to create some signal
through the noise that's going on at the
moment then yeah it feels like a pretty
good use of my time that being said I
also appreciate that giving you
interesting and different topics which
actually help to distract you and remind
you that there is a world out there
aside from the virus which is running
rampant across the globe I'm gonna do
that as well so normal service will be
continued to be resumed soon but for now
please welcome the wise and wonderful
Morgan Housel oh yeah PS if you enjoyed
this episode with Morgan you will love
his new book the psychology of money and
it is available for pre-order now by
following the link in the show notes
below
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back Morgan
we said we weren't going to have to
speak until your new book comes out at
the end of summer and look at us now two
weeks later and we're talking again
that's how fast the world changes and I
think that's I mean we just jump right
in so I think that's been the
interesting thing of what's happened in
the last two weeks is how it's not what
happened
it's how fast it happened but if you
look at the long history of stock
markets markets falling 25% is not
uncommon at all it's something that on
happens happens every four years or so
going back to the last hundred year for
it to happen this fast is unprecedented
this is literally the fastest it's ever
occurred so I think that to me if
there's anything that's shocking that's
happened in the last couple weeks from a
financial perspective the health
perspective is a different is a
different topic altogether but for
investing perspective it's the the speed
in which this is occur that's amazing
what are the headlines
what's the headlines in terms of
financial activity over the last two
weeks what has happened well here's that
let me let me start by saying this in a
normal recession in a bad recession you
might have sales in certain industries
down 5% 10% maybe if it's a really bad
recession in a specific industry 20%
that's bad what we're dealing with here
is a different magnitude you haven't
hired geographic regions where sales are
down 80% you know and so there's there's
really no modern precedent for that
because it's not like a recession where
people pull back a little bit this is
just shut down and it's almost like the
only precedent for that in recent
somewhat recent times is literally like
world war 2 now I don't want to equate
those in significance but in terms of
just an economy shutting down just
stopping overnight you know that's not
really something that we have much
experience with and I think it's
important to say that since we don't
have a lot of precedent for what's going
on no one knows what's gonna happen next
there's really just there's not a
playbook that we can learn from history
that's gonna tell us what a lot of
what's gonna happen next we always say
the next recession is never like the
last one and when we say that we always
feel like well it's gonna be a little
different yeah but all recessions gonna
have a similar
trajectory and whatnot but this is just
a different a different thing altogether
and of course we don't even know what's
gonna happen next in terms of shutdowns
and lock downs let alone what the
recovery afterwards might look like so
we're recording this March 13th
yesterday on the 12th was that the
biggest move that we've seen so far was
that the largest market move from top to
bottom ah ah yes in in percentage terms
the US stock market fell just about 10%
which the only other single day that was
worse than that was 1987 the crash of
1987 and some days during the Great
Depression in 1929 in the in 1987 I
think the market fell 22% in one day and
in the Great Depression you had about
three consecutive days where it fell 10
to 15% each day but other than those two
episodes yesterday was was the worst so
if you've lived through it and you
survived it congratulations this is what
this is this is the big leagues now
Wow yeah this is squeaky bum time I
think is my dad as my dad would colic so
real yeah so we've talked about what's
actually happening in terms of some of
the businesses right so the economy
within countries and the market move as
well which one of these is going to have
the biggest economic impact do we think
I think you would have to say well it's
interesting because here's the two sides
of it you know China just kind of
because of its political structure was
able to effectively create firm
lockdowns across a very large swath of
its country 50 million people were on
100% lockdown more or less so that's
gonna be the biggest economic hit
because everything just came to a stop
and you have these statistics like
gambling revenue and mchale was down 90
percent month-over-month and Chinese car
sales were down 90 percent in February
from the previous year because
everything just came to a stop so I
think China's gonna have the biggest hit
but they also might have one of the
fastest recoveries because they kind of
took their medicine really quick and now
they got the curve under control and now
maybe they can start going back to
something that looks
normal whereas in the United States
where and Italy in other countries in
Europe where just because of the how the
politics are structure how the
government structure you cannot just
come in and shut the economy down and
tell people to stay in their houses and
you'll be arrested if you leave we said
it's not happening yeah therefore you
know our our the the short term hit that
we might take might be less but I have a
feeling it's just going to be a much
more dragged out process to both
experience the downturn and then a
slowness in the recovery afterwards I
think one analogy for that is also
people are familiar with the Great
Depression of the 1930s and what was bad
about the Great Depression was that it
was not only deep it was very long it
lasted for several years from about
nineteen twenty nine until 1933 or 34b
things started turning around there was
also another depression in 1920 in the
United States and basically it was world
where one had just ended we were kind of
switching the economy from wartime
footing to normal footing and then
there's a lot of disruptions so there
was a very bad depression in 1919 1920
and it was extremely deep it was
actually deeper than the Great
Depression but some measures but it was
fast it was two or three quarters of a
big big hit but then things kind of
bounced back really quickly and and and
since it bounced back pretty quickly
like it didn't make history like the
Great Depression did because what was so
bad about the Great Depression was the
length and maybe that's an appropriate
analogy for maybe China goes through
something like our 1920 Depression and
maybe for other people I I do not think
that we're gonna be you know looking at
something that's equitable to the Great
Depression but maybe that's a similar
analogy that it's gonna be maybe not
quite as deep as China's but just more
drawn out and the other thing that's so
different about what we're dealing with
right now relative to past recessions is
that this is a being caused by biology
it's not being caused by business
problems which is very different from
all past recessions that we've been
through if you think about 2008 a lot of
the reason that the recovery after 2008
you know as we got into 2010 2011 2012 a
lot of the reason it was so slow to
recover and there was not just a fierce
bounce-back
was because the 2008 was caused by
business problems whereas this what
we're going through right now is being
caused by biology and so that also it
brings an element that I think people
who study these things just don't really
know what you know what's gonna happen
now because we don't have a lot of
experience with that but it also means
like that let's say and I I'm not a
doctor or a biologist so I have
absolutely no authority to say this but
let's say that in the next four months
six months one year whatever there is
some effective treatment or even a
vaccine if we're looking out the next
year year and a half you know there is
no equivalent of a vaccine in 2008 we
just had to grind through it we just had
to take the medicine it just have to
look like okay we just got to do this
yeah but you could see that if there is
an effect and again I need to preface
this so hard with the I have no idea
what I'm talking about here but let's
just say in three months there's a
headline that says so and so laboratory
has discovered ineffective treatment or
you know a vaccine is looking really is
looking really good
that could bring back so much economic
activity because the problems right now
are not business they're not economic as
biology so I think this has a potential
to spring back faster than previous
recessions that we've been through and I
say potential because I don't know if
that's exactly what's gonna happen but
it has potential that did not exist in
2008 for this to be very more severe
than 2008 but also recover quicker and
faster than we did in 2008 yeah
everything that we're saying just has to
have a million caveats behind it doesn't
it because it's so very unprecedented at
the moment that is the word right
economically unprecedented so you you've
touched on it they're just so we've got
it definitively are you saying that
there's essentially nothing that that
analogous to the situation we're in
right now that's ever occurred I think
it's probably pretty close the only
thing that would be similar again and
it's very different of course but I
think the only thing similar is probably
world war two we're in a relatively
short period of time you had pretty much
the entire global economy just shifted
immediately and
just the regular order of life was
completely disrupted now it was it was
very different and I don't know I'd have
no idea you know 80 million people died
in World War two I have absolutely no
clue what's gonna happen here but I
think in just in terms of the severity
of the change to the regular order of
life that is probably the closest
analogy because you think of the other
major recessions in 2008 in 2001 1974
1980 just a very very different set of
circumstances that we were dealing with
people had money problems but they were
not afraid to go to go to the restaurant
they maybe they maybe they could not
afford to go to the restaurant but once
they had money they were not afraid to
go to the restaurant where now you're
looking at a situation where people are
afraid for their health and there's
another big thing here which is that in
2008 the consequences of getting caught
up in the tragedy of 2008 was you're
gonna lose your job now that's a big
deal I do not want to minimize that but
now the consequences of getting caught
up with coronaviruses you might die and
that's just a completely different
psychological sense of being raised the
stakes have been raised so much and
again I don't want to minimize the
trauma of losing your job particularly
if you're a working parent or something
but the stakes are just much different
now I think whenever you say the word
die then people's propensity to over to
react and I I don't even want to say
overreact because an overreaction might
be the rational thing but you're going
to get to get a much deeper reaction
than we have for people who are used to
studying how recessions play out so it's
just a totally different set of
circumstances here but let me also say
one thing and I don't know if this is a
good analogy or not but I was speaking
with a friend right before this and and
we started talking about something that
I thought was very interesting and maybe
this is something that you know more
than me about but I was talking about
the the London Blitz in World War Two in
the in 1940 when London was being bombed
by the Germans night after night after
night and it was an absolute tragedy of
course I've read stories to the effect
of this in the early days everyone was
completely petrified did
not want to leave their homes hunkering
down in their bunkers as you would
expect of course and then as the days
and weeks went on at least for some
people there was a growing sense of look
we have to just move on we cannot live
in shelters our entire lives we just
have to go about our lives and accept
the risk of what we're facing I'm
probably over generalizing that I want
to be sensitive to the situation that I
did not experience but I was speaking
with a friend and I said I wonder if
that's an appropriate analogy that right
now we are in the panic face pretty much
across the world but I wonder as the
weeks and maybe months go on that even
if things do not get in better and this
keeps spreading
I wonder into the Excel to what extent
are people just gonna say look I cannot
live in my basement washing my hands 40
times a day anymore we have to just
accept the risk and go back on with our
lives I don't know if that's true yeah I
think there is precedent for at some
point people just start getting
accustomed to the risks in their life
even if those risks are very large it's
and once they get accustomed to them
once those risks are not new anymore
then they're willing more willing to
just say look at this as risky
some of us are gonna die like let that's
true but we need to go about our lives
we just need to go do this I don't know
if that's the case but it's an
interesting thing to think about I
couldn't agree more yeah it's um it's
like a reverse hedonic adaptation isn't
it exactly yeah
like I've got used to this new the last
podcast that we did was talking about
people getting accustomed to their new
levels of wealth NBA players who this
any other whereas now it's almost the
opposite of that one way in which I can
see this situation being very different
to the Blitz in terms of people's
response is that you going outside and
putting your own life in danger during
the Blitz did not endanger the lives of
anybody else whereas the ancillary
analogous kind of the the orthogonal
problems that you're gonna come up
against by leaving let's say that you
leave the house because you're just
going to get on with your day but you
get infected then bring it back then in
fact the rest of your family
that I think is playing on so many
people's minds you know like this so
she'll Kosti what is it that Navarre
says where he talks about privatized
gain versus socialized loss and you know
that's what that's what the person who
decides to go to work just so that they
can continue to get money despite having
a cough that is the situation that we're
playing ourselves with and there's no
you totally right the UK and America
there's no martial law implemented
there's nothing stopping me if I get a
dry cough and I think I know it'll be
fine I'll be okay
I could do with making some money this
week I'm just gonna crack on and go to
work if I decide if I decide to do that
that's putting other people
unnecessarily at risk and that is a
great point I think that's why the the
difference lies yeah totally I think
that's totally true especially when the
biggest risk that you're gonna be if you
go out and catch it yourself and then
you come home and you're with your
spouse and your kids or your parents
your in-laws whoever it is that's living
with you it's like the people you're
gonna put at risk are the people who are
closest to you and you love the most
which is adds a different element it's
different in that sense yeah yeah um so
I want to talk about the the markets and
and sort of how and why they've
responded in this way we've spoken about
the fact that they've moved what did you
say 25% down is that right that that's
that's ratha it was it was 27 this
morning and now we heard a big up day so
yeah let's let's let's call it 25 okay
cool yeah well even out a nice around
25% in the red um why is that happened
for people who maybe have a only basic
understanding of economic theory have
people have investors just said I'm
gonna pull my money out what they're
doing is it's sitting in their bank
account at the moment of people deciding
are they literally going out and trying
to buy bars of gold like what's happened
well let's let's keep two things in mind
here that I think are important is that
one whenever there's been a tremendous
amount of selling very quickly very
vicious selling like we've seen in
recent weeks there's there's several
kinds of investors that might be causing
that one is that I think is really
important that has grown in importance
over the last 10 or 20 years are these
computer algorithms that are literally
just automating
programs it's not a person typing in
cell orders into their into their each
raid account
celebrities computer algorithms that are
making the trades by themselves by the
the knowledge that is invested in the
algorithm and a lot of those algorithms
can especially during very volatile
times can go kind of haywire and so how
much of what's been going on in the last
couple weeks is not necessarily human
fear but just computer saying this isn't
right sell sell no no that's not right
this correlation looks weird to me so
sell sell so we don't know but I suspect
it's quite a bit we don't know what the
measurement of that is but that there's
there's that element into interject
there Morgan that's the first time that
we'll have had such a proliferation of
expert advisors slash algorithmic
trading right you know in 2008 2009 we
would have had some but it's now going
to be ratcheted it up even more so so
this is again another parameter another
variable that is affecting the current
economic market which we haven't seen
before
I think that's probably right it was it
was actually fairly large in 2008 but it
you're right that it is bigger and I
think it's it's definitely more
sophisticated today and sophistication I
might put in air quotes because
oftentimes you know rather than
sophistication maybe the word is complex
and complex can do some weird outcomes
when we have when we're getting wild in
these times like we have right today so
it's important to realize that when
there's a tremendous amount of selling
it doesn't necessarily mean a human is
scared it's just someone is selling out
there the other thing is look these are
different economic times like the
numbers that we've put around about in
China car sales down 90 percent and who
knows what its gonna be in the United
States I've spoken with some friends who
are small business owners who their
sales are down 50 60 70 % in the last
week so there is just a ratcheting down
of economic expectations relative to
where we were three weeks ago public
companies are not going to be as
profitable over the next year maybe more
than they were three weeks ago so
there's that and then there is also
another thing to keep in mind here kind
of the counter to all of this which is
that it's very often to look at the
headlines or to watch CNBC and
the conclusion that investors are
panicked people are panicked and they're
selling which is true but there's a very
important caveat which is that what
you're seeing is just the marginal
transaction and what's important is that
during these times the huge vast
majority of investors in the high 90
percents are not doing anything so one
of my favorite statistics was the last
time we had kind of a big crazy 20%
sell-off was the summer of 2011 a lot of
people don't remember that anymore but
in summer of 2011 it looked like we were
heading back into financial crisis 2.0
that we were gonna head back into the
Great Recession and a lot of people then
it got it got really dicey for a while
stock markets fell about 20% during that
period in August 2011 when markets fell
20% 98 percent of Vanguard investors
Vanguard being you know the largest
investing platform in the world did not
make a single transaction 98 percent so
it's so easy to look at that period and
say everyone's panicked and the answer's
no a very small percentage of people are
panicked and they're making transactions
and those transactions are having an
influence on the going price of stocks
but 98 percent of people are not only
err that I'm doing everything a lot of
people's aren't even paying attention
like trillions of dollars out that that
is invested in the market is for people
that you know invest in their company
401ks and every paycheck they put a
couple hundred bucks into the 401k and
most of those people don't even know the
password to their brokerage account any
attention to what's going on so to me
that's always like an important context
when I think it's easy to say everyone's
panicking no they're not some
professional investors are panicking and
some individuals are too but the
majority of people are just going about
their day right now that's always
important to remember when things are
getting crazy yeah we see the the scenes
from Wall Street right with the guys
shaking those pieces of paper in the in
the air and we think oh my god like that
that's a microcosm which is their the
representative for so many other people
around the world and you're totally
correct especially when you're dealing
with a global pandemic people are
thinking about how can I make sure that
me and my family are safe have I got
enough food in the house what's going to
happen to my kids and my kids gonna be
sent home from
school you totally right they're not
thinking about the finer points of of
trading and bits and pieces like that
I've I've got a note that I made during
the week since I knew that we were going
to do this you made an analogy that I
think it was a tale from your grandma
where she said the difference between
camping is fun and being homeless is
miserable and it was it was talking
about that and I realized this week that
a meditation retreat is fun but house
arrest in Italy is also miserable and
that's right a perfect analogy you know
like this there's people who decide I'm
gonna spend a little bit of time at home
with the family this week I'm gonna
decide I might might go and decorate the
house I might do a few of the bits and
pieces but when that's mandated by your
government because there's a pandemic
running riot outside in the streets it's
a lot less fun absolutely I think that's
true I'll give you I'll give you my
personal example this past Christmas
break I took about ten days off of work
and we didn't travel anywhere we stayed
home and it was really bad weather so I
didn't do anything outside so I spent
about ten days on the couch listening to
podcasts reading books and it was so
much fun I loved it it was just great
ten days of just leisure and reading and
learning but you're absolutely right
that if I if we went into lockdown here
and then it was I have to spend the next
ten days or two weeks or whatever
sitting on the couch reading books I'd
probably be miserable just because yeah
right okay so I want to know what you
have changed your mind on in the last
few weeks anything that that comes to
the forefront of your brain that you've
changed your mind on or a new
perspective that you've gained over the
last couple of weeks
I don't I don't want this to sound flip
it but I don't I don't think the answer
is anything and maybe there's two
reasons for that one is that I just
don't know enough yet
like maybe as in the next month I'll
learn something else that's going on
about the progress of the disease or the
known fatality rate whatever it is that
will make me change my worldview but the
other reason I don't think I've changed
my mind about is because all of my
investing philosophy starting well
before this has been the case for years
more than a decade has been based around
the concept of survive
just if I want my investing strategies
to be based around endurance so that I
can put up with upheaval and kind of
inherent in that is that I am always
expecting and prepared for major
upheaval I don't know what's going to
cause it or when it's going to come or
how severe its gonna be or how quickly
it's gonna come but I'm always prepared
for for stuff to hit the fan so to speak
so and I think that's not true for a lot
of investors a lot of investors when
they experience a 20% decline it's see
they never expected it or even if they
like in theory expected it they kind of
thought it would never happen and so
they're really taking a off guard when
that happens whereas I'm and maybe this
is just indicative of my personality I'm
kind of a worst case scenario worrier
but I'm always under the impression that
stuff like this is gonna happen and I've
written about this before I keep a much
higher percentage of my assets in cash
then most people of my age would and the
reason is because I think I'm always
worried about stuff like this and once
stuff like this happens I want to make
sure that my endurance is in place so
that I can not have to freak out I've
got a question here from someone on
Twitter who DM me and said Morgan once
alluded to the fact that he basically
hoards cash is a security blanket fully
knowing is damaging long term and
diluting his returns but protects him in
situations like that is he still that
way today I guess you've just at least
in one one form answered that it's the
answer is yes and I would actually I
would actually add to that in terms of
not you know to get personal about my
situation here but my my wife is a
stay-at-home mother I have two young
kids on the sole breadwinner if anything
I've probably gotten more paranoid
because everything in my whole family's
stability is on my shoulders here so if
anything I've gotten more paranoid and
but I'll tell you it does not bother me
a single bit even let's rewind the clock
to a month ago and markets were at
all-time highs of course I could go back
and do the calculation and say hey if my
if I had invested some of this more cat
some of this cash in stocks over the
past 10 years
my net worth would be X percent higher
and it does not bother me in the
slightest
i-i've always said in the sky I don't
expect this to be the case for everyone
so I'm not saying everyone should do
this but I am I do not manage my money
to achieve the highest returns I manage
my money to get the best night of sleep
and because of that it does not bother
me in the slightest that I'm giving up
some returns I should also say when I
say I have a lot of cash it's not it's
not crazy amount it's not like I'm 90%
of my money in cash or anything it's not
a mattress full that you and your missus
asleep I'm having to rearrange each
night because the hundreds are under her
head this week instead of yours yeah
it's no it's nothing like that I mean if
it depends how you measure it as a
percentage of our assets or percentage
of our equities but you know it's
probably something like you know we have
five times as much stock as we do as we
do cash so like 20% the portfolio some
it's something it changes based on a lot
of different variables of however you
want to measure it but it's it's it's
not a crazy percentage is this higher
than most people in my situation would
but it's because and I wouldn't even say
it's because I'm conservative or I don't
want to take a risk it's that I value
endurance more than any other investment
variable because once you have endurance
and once you have just rock-solid
endurance that's when you can really let
compounding work over long periods of
time because when you face a period like
we have over the last month you're not
gonna get knocked on your butt and get
knocked over you're gonna say look I
have the cash to withstand this I can
put up with this I'm just gonna full
speed ahead let's go and once you say
that that's really when compounding
works miracles over a very long period
of time once you have the endurance to
not get knocked down during these
headwinds it's so much more powerful to
do that than it is to and you know
really maximize for ROI and have all of
your cash invested in stocks and then
you hit a bad period where maybe you get
laid off or whatever happens the normal
you know banana peels of life that
people slip on and during a market down
during the market market decline you
suddenly say you have to panic sell at
the bottom or something like that that
is a situation that's going to dent your
returns far more than having a big slug
of cash during a bull market
yeah it's choosing to make a little bit
less over a long
of time versus risking losing a lot in a
short space of time right there's a
financial advisor named Carl Richards
who writes about this and he I'm
paraphrasing here I might I might
butcher this but he says you know it's
it's about exchanging the opportunity to
make to make a killing in exchange for
making sure that you don't get killed
yeah and that's that's really what I'm
going for I just want to make sure I
don't get killed as an investor and I'm
willing to exchange not making a killing
in order to make sure that I never get
killed I wonder how many people will be
learning that lesson right now you know
people have a lot yeah yeah and I don't
there's no shading fried in there I feel
bad for those people but it's it's a
lesson that a lot of people wore learn
some harris tweed one of the cleverest
things I've seen so far which is totally
not to do with finance but is analogous
to what we're talking about here where
he said the mortality of this virus it's
between 2 and 4% fish we can say it
between there um this is a dry run for
something that's a lot more vicious and
as shown it's just how poorly prepared
we are for it and the interconnectedness
and fat-tailed probability and all that
stuff all the reasons as to why it's
it's been able to spread so quickly but
imagine if this was MERS or Ebola with
mortality of 30% or 50% but the
infection rate was still people being
able to infect others whilst being
asymptomatic and it dragged out over a
long period of time and blah blah blah
you know that would be that you're
talking existential like end of humanity
type stuff so again with that you know
one of the things that people can take
it
there's not many positives to take from
this situation but one of them is it
could be worse there are by a number of
parameters that this could be worse it
just looping back as well to what you'd
said there about your survivability and
that long term thing I'm just going to
start to read from something you tweeted
earlier on today which I absolutely love
and it's Charlie Munger in 2009 asked
being asked how worried he was that
stocks had fallen by 50% and this is his
quote zero this is the third time Warren
and I have seen our holdings go down top
tick to bottom tick by 50% I think it's
in the nature of long-term shareholding
of the normal vicissitudes of worldly
outcomes of markets that the long-term
holder has his quoted value of his
stocks God
by say 50% and essentially if you're not
willing to react with equanimity to the
market price decline in 50% 2 or 3 times
a century you're not fit to be a common
shareholder and you deserve the mediocre
result you're going to get oh my god for
his he's known for his blunt language
but I think that gets back to another
kind of point what I was saying is that
these major hits and they always they
always look different and come in
different forms come from different
areas but to take a major hit to lose
30% 20% 50% of your money is something
that you as if you're a long-term
investor you should expect with 100%
certainty that that's going to happen
these are these are not these these
should not be surprises it's not to say
that they're fun when they occur but you
should not expect the whole reason that
stocks are capable of producing great
long-term returns is because these
things happen if you don't want to deal
with this then you can put your money in
a savings account and earn half of 1%
and you don't have to deal with any ups
and downs but if you want to earn 10% a
year over on your money over the long
haul you need to put up with the fact
that every couple years you might lose
20 or 30 or 50 percent of it for a
somewhat short period of time who knows
how long and then it'll come back that's
the price of admission to the markets
and it's it's it's unfortunate of course
when people are reminded or they learn
the cost of admission after they've
entered the theme-park so to speak but
this is this is the cost of it this is
this is the payment that you that the
market requires that you pay in order to
go on this glorious ride over ten or
twenty or thirty years and if you're not
willing to pay it you're gonna have a
real hard time
I mean for the people who haven't heard
my first episode of Morgan it will be
linked in the show notes below and I
employ you to go back and listen to it
because so many of the lessons which you
gave us then apply now what was it that
we talked about we spoke about the fact
that so few people in the West have at
least one month's salary in the bank
that they're living paycheck to paycheck
people are very highly leveraged through
talking about the fact that you need to
ensure that you earn more than you spend
on a consistent basis and all of these
things right now this is the situation
this is where you get down to brass
tax and you see who has that that in
reserve and those lessons if people had
heeded those lessons for the last ten
years to be fine people who haven't
heeded those lessons for the last ten
years are gonna be a little bit less
fine so I wanted to talk about you you
can't give a Morgan Housel z-- how to
survive a financial apocalypse but have
you got any tips for what people can do
some of the the even if they're just
mental strategies rather than financial
strategies how would you go about it
I mean it's so different for everyone
because everyone's got a different
financial situation a different job
situation different family needs and
whatnot I mean III can just tell you how
I'm coming in from it from my own
perspective sure I'm you know I've well
I mean the first thing I did was just to
have a lot of preparation for this event
now that's that's not advice for someone
who did not prepare for this but I I
have a lot of cash we have some
flexibility you know and a lot of the
stuff is just unique to our financial
situation it's not going to be not
applicable to other people but yeah yeah
you know the other thing and this is a
different personality as well too but my
family can live very very cheaply and
still have a good time we can have a
good time going for a walk going to a
park going to the library and checking
out books we do not we're not a big
local and a big high-maintenance family
and that becomes such an important asset
if economic times get rough because if
you have to if you this gets back to the
camping versus homeless thing if you are
forced to cut back your lifestyle it
hurts if you're forced to do it if you
wanted you want to drive the nice car
but you you can't afford it anymore that
that that's a painful thing if you're
forced to do it but if you have the kind
of situation where it's like no honestly
if my wife and I if my family and I you
know we're billionaires and we would
never will be but if we were we would
still spend our Saturday going for a
walk down by the river it's just what we
enjoy doing and it doesn't cost any
money so I think to the extent that
people can find hobbies that do not cost
any money that it sounds it sounds trite
but that's probably the best thing that
you can do during a tough economic time
I know that that sounds silly that's not
exactly financial advice but I think
it's like honestly the most powerful
thing you can
is to keep your expectations low but do
it in a way that doesn't feel like
you're being forced to cut back you're
just finding new hobbies that don't cost
a lot of money if that makes sense
couldn't agree more I think that that
resetting of the hedonic set point you
know would endure how many people in
this situation will actually be given
renewed vigor I mean renewed love for
simpler pleasures you know like it's
rare some of the things I've been
thinking about which don't really touch
on finances that much but it's very rare
that globally everybody is dealing with
something you know like it doesn't even
rain everywhere in the world at the same
time my draining countries in the same
at the same time it doesn't even ray
so I was thinking earlier on like you'll
have seen this the World Cup Sun or the
Olympics are on or some reality TVs on
or whatever it might be when people in
the modern world have the opportunity to
band together behind a common experience
that all of them are having you get an
incredible sense of unity and a very
unique opportunity to actually see what
happens
bizarrely when people are brought
together and I can't remember it's one
of the X American presidents who was
talking about how how much we would all
be united if we were against a common
foe that was from a different planet you
know like the divisions the divisions
between countries and territories would
be forgotten almost instantly and this
is kind of it you know there's some
people that he wanted blame China and
almost be I suppose racialized the virus
against the East but really everyone's
just going look we're all in this
together [ __ ] like I feel so bad for
Italy I feel so bad for Wuhan I feel so
bad for this country [ __ ] like you know
we we need to do our bit and we need to
do this than any other and it is in the
strangest way possible the this a
bringing together of people under this
catastrophe that seems quite rare I
think that's either
100% right that was that was I was said
very well and it's it's it's true now if
there is you know a devil's advocate to
that and you sort of alluded to this
it's still if you watch the cable news
outlets its finger pointing left and
right I think that's not going to go
away but you're right that I was
actually thinking today and I didn't I
didn't tweet this but I'm gonna say it
on the podcast anyways cuz it might be
wrong I'm not I'm not
you know claiming this but I think this
might be the biggest global event since
World War two is that it events within
countries there have been Rwanda
genocide you go down the list but global
in terms of something that's like
happening to him almost everyone at the
same time this might be the biggest
things that's world war two i I didn't
know I I didn't I didn't tweet that
because I might be wrong about that so
if there's a listener who says no you're
forgetting this I'm open to being wrong
but I think it's close to that it's
definitely gonna be up there man yeah
yeah and is is bizarre to so think about
what does this mean because the virus is
a very unique equalizer doesn't care
whether you're rich or poor doesn't care
where you live what country you're in
doesn't care who your mom and dad are if
you get it like there's different
strains but the effects are exactly the
same you're in you know you're you're in
the same place from the king in his
castle to the pauper in the street
they're all in the same position now I
know that's a hundred percent true which
is very different from like Vietnam in
the United States where rich people
could more or less buy their way out of
the draft then when there were ways to
get around it if there is a caveat to
that especially in the United States
unfortunately is that health care does
is biased towards income so whether you
whether you add whether you catch the
virus might not be and for some people
actually is because if you don't have
paid time off work you're more inclined
to go to work if you've not even getting
paid and you might be more as you know
susceptible to getting it but then
health care afterwards is so biased
towards income in the United States it's
a it's a big it's a big problem but I
think you're totally right that in terms
of something that Americans and Italians
and Iranians and Chinese and British
everyone French just we're all in the
same boat together
and it's like you know I'm not any
expert honest
but my understanding is that China very
quickly you know posted the genetic
sequence of of kovat online like
globally to anyone like open source like
let's just try to figure this all out
together you guys so that's it that's a
cool thing like it's too early to be
looking for silver linings of this would
just not do that yet but it's not
unfathomable to think that a year from
now two years from now we look back and
say like that was actually a really cool
thing that we all did together it's not
to minimize what might happen but I
think you're totally right yeah you are
correct
there could be some great ways to
transcend the suffering in the
catastrophe that comes from this virus
by the learning by the models that we
have by extra preparation as we move
forward I can't know what it was I was
listening to the other day but it's
something like I think 20 million n95
masks could be made for the price of one
tenth of a fighter jet like and we I
think the US are desperately trying to
get like half a million and it would
make some huge change or whatever it
might be want another question I've got
with regards to finances do you think
that the market has fully priced in how
the epidemic can go yet or is it still
just just reacting daily I think it's
it's priced in a tremendous amount of
what might happen like by any measure a
25% decline is big its pricing in a lot
of bad news but no one not a single
person knows what's gonna happen next
so it's possible that we've already way
overreacted that's possible it's
possible that we've we've barely
scratched the surface of what's gonna
happen I don't know and nobody knows so
I don't think no markets are not being
complacent whenever there's a 25%
decline in ten days there's no
complacency but there's still just a big
question mark we just got to see what's
gonna happen what was it if someone
tells you they know what's gonna happen
you know ask them for their forecasts
one year ago that said a virus called
probe it's gonna ruin the world you know
if you didn't see this coming a year ago
you have no right telling you what's
gonna happen over the next year man what
a quote yeah I absolutely love that what
was it that you were saying
I think it was a graph a graph of
perhaps the footsie 200 and you'd
highlighted on it about when the
different forecasts were made all the
way along it and then there's just this
bit where the corona focus gets released
and you were like no but anybody that
tells you what they they have an idea
about what's going on is so far wrong
here yeah you know the the biggest risk
this is always true this is not unique
to the last couple months the biggest
risk that we face is always what nobody
is talking about and by deficit by
definition we have no idea and then it's
funny whenever when I said that in the
past I've had interviewers would be like
okay so what is nobody talking about
right now and I'm like no like nobody
including like nobody is talking about
it it's something that we cannot
envision and just like if you went back
six months from now not a single person
on the entire planet could have said
well there's gonna be this corona virus
that's gonna like no one could have said
that that's always the case wasn't it I
let you do all of the different people
that were talking about whether or not I
could in interest rates or a change in
employment law was going to make a
difference and then coronavirus just
comes in and shakes the actor sketch and
wipes everything off yes we spent 10
years debating who's gonna cause the
next recession is that Barack Obama is
that Ben Bernanke is a Donald Trump is
it Janet Yellen no it's a virus a virus
so that's I think if that doesn't give
you humility in your forecasting then
nothing will so that's when it's not a
comfortable answer I get this but no one
knows what's gonna happen next and my
proof from that is no one knew no one
knew that this was gonna happen to begin
with I couldn't agree more man so a lot
of the questions that I got have been
from people talking about right when
when do we react when is it a good idea
to invest in big companies that we hope
will recover what are the signs that are
going to show that they're recovering
and stuff like that is it even possible
to model at this stage well the
important thing and this is always true
and I know this will be true this time
around too is that the stock market is
going to rebound well before the real
economy rebounds that's always how it
happens the stock market bottomed and
then started rebounding in March of
thousand nine after the financial crisis
the real economy really didn't start
getting better until early 2010 even
into 2011 so the stock market always
happens way before that so if people
wait for businesses to start recovering
the stock markets arguing going to have
been recovered that's that's always the
case that'll be true this time
so my recommendation for that is to say
look you should really think hard about
how much cash and liquidity that you
need everyone's different they have
different job prospects different job
security different cost structures etc
but think about how much cash you need
and then once you have that secured I
just dollar cost average into the market
that's always what I do and I don't
think that's gonna change so that would
that would be my advice to people is it
gets dangerous if you say I'm gonna look
for signs that businesses have bottomed
that's that's not a winning investing
strategy you got to get any well before
that and the only way you're gonna get
in before that is to kind of make it
systematic and just say I'm gonna invest
X dollars every month and then that's it
just keep it simple like that so you
just piece into the market slowly over
time is that right over time that's it
yeah and I have my cash on the side that
keeps me safe it's my security blanket
at night and after that it's just
dribbling and consistently over time
that's it I get it so is that I saw a
comment someone hoods but he wasn't on
creel actually so Anton creel had
tweeted the other day that he'd been
asked how does he feel ethically about
making money in a situation like this
and I wondered what you and potentially
some of the people that you're exposed
to your friends if they ever have an
ethical consideration you know this is
any movement in the market is an
opportunity for people to make money and
drastic movements in the market a
drastic opportunities for people to make
money do you ever think like God like
you know there's some friends that
you'll have in there that will have been
rubbing their hands together because
they've been able to play the stock
market in a good way and this
opportunity to come to them do you think
that people have a little bit of guilt
in that I don't know I think there's two
separate things I don't know and this is
not what you're referring to but there's
a story today about a guy who went
around to every Costco he could and
bought out the Clorox wipes and he's
selling him for a hundred times market
like that's that
that's a profiteering that I would feel
morally corrupt about of course but I
think if you were just saying this stock
is cheap and I'm gonna buy it because I
think it's gonna go up no I think
there's absolutely nothing no moral
guilt in that because especially markets
going up to the extent that you are a
buyer and you are doing your your
marginal part to help markets go up that
affects a huge swath of the population
that's not just rich people that's goes
down to pensions and endowments that
affect a large chunk of the population
so I don't think there should be any
moral guilt about buying when stocks
have plunged if anything I'd say it's
the other way around it's almost like
look this is not your your full
patriotic duty but I do think there's a
patriotic duty to pay like you know the
player part and keeping the financial
system together a big part of that is
not participating like in a bank run
which we don't have many of them anymore
because we have we have insurance on her
deposits but that you know that's a bank
run is an example of how you can be you
know going against your patriotic duty
to keep the financial system together so
and look if people need to sell their
stocks I don't think they should feel
guilty about that either you got to take
care of your own needs in a market is
the market you can buy or sell whenever
you want but no I definitely don't think
people should feel guilty about it
particularly if their wealth is gonna
help them secure their family's future
the family's foundation I think it's a
wonderful thing that we should be proud
of I get it so is this an opportunity
for somebody who has a solid amount of
liquid cash to make money over the next
year the next few years I would I would
say yes but but I would put a caveat on
the last part of what you said which was
over the next year next few years I
don't know I don't know if this is gonna
clear up next week I don't know if this
is gonna take ten years I don't know
yeah as a long-term investor who's
looking at truly the next generation I'm
investing for the next 30 years I hope
to pass along assets to my children you
know when when that is my time range
then I don't necessarily care whether
this is gonna take six months or a year
or ten years it's not really a factor
that's gonna materially change how I
invest
so that's the only caveat I would put on
to that I think this this is an
opportunity as long as you have a very
flexible time horizon in front of you
yeah and it's also it's also not to say
that even though it this might be an
opportunity today that does not that is
not to say that this might not get much
worse from here those are two separate
things
it might get much worse from here
there's just so many unknowns isn't that
you know like I yeah and having an
unknown is so like having a very bad
known thing does not hurt as much as
having a little bit of uncertainty if
that makes sense
like I mean here's an example and
there's making this up if I if I punched
you hard in the leg right now it might
hurt but it's just like it's an own
thing and it's over whereas if I said
Chris at some point in the next 24 hours
unexpectedly I'm gonna punch you with
medium strength in the leg that would
bother you more than if I hit you really
hard really quickly and just got it over
with like having it unknown and question
mark is so much more painful than a
known pain well and so it's it's hard
for everyone and it really affects your
long-term thinking it's hard to it's
hard to think about the next year when
the world as you know it changed in the
last 48 hours very difficult to do that
so it's like that amount of uncertainty
just means that when people are looking
ahead in their future it used to be if
you roll back two months ago people had
me oh my thing most people had a pretty
good view of what their next year would
look like they know that they're gonna
do this they're gonna live here they're
gonna work there and now people are like
I don't know what's gonna happen like
are we gonna be on lockdown tomorrow I
don't know yeah uncertainty is very is
very hard as mentally to deal with does
that Larry Summers quote which you
tweeted the other day which was a good
rule of thumb for many things in life
holds that things take longer to happen
than you think they will and then happen
faster than you thought they could and
as that other one I can't know what the
other one floating around which is
it takes decades for nothing to happen
and then sometimes decades happen in no
time at all exactly there's another
quote from from Talib who says history
does not crawl it leaps and that's true
the biggest events of history happen
overnight and I think it happened in the
last week and its really interest so
back to Larry Summers quote no one
predicted that the economic expansion
the bull market would last this long
nobody it lasted much longer than anyone
thought and it has now come to an end
faster than anyone thought as well it's
mine from an economics perspective this
must be a fascinating thing to study and
will be a fascinating thing to study for
a significant amount of time I'm gonna
guess it's it's true but I can tell you
for myself as someone who study these
things more or less for a living of
course I'm I'm you know is it
fascinating sure but I'm worried about
my parent self I'm worried about my
family's health so there's it's it's
this weird thing of like yes this is
fascinating but it's also like it's a
scary time for everyone you know yeah
yeah it is and that's I think both of me
and you have today said a lot of things
with trepidation and kind of tried to
tread carefully on the ice because we
know that it's a a traumatic and
difficult time for a lot of people and
yet in the same sentence it's also fair
to say that it's an opportunity for
growth it's also an opportunity to make
money it's also a time that we should be
studying there's also some potential
good things which should come out of it
and you know I think I haven't seen much
yet online of people being called out
for being insensitive to these sorts of
things I do believe that people are
actually a little bit more attuned to
the nuance of some of these arguments at
the moment we have which actually makes
me feel really confident I'm glad that
it's the case that people aren't jumping
down each other's necks about this you
are right there is some some
finger-pointing but not well I don't
think this is as much as there as there
could be it does feel like people are
banding together
there's a great book written by an
author named Sebastian Junger the book
is called tribes and it's a very short
book you can read it in two hours and
just talks about kind of the social
consequences of being in a tribe and
tribes take very different forms there's
Native American tribes where there's
also just like colleges as a tribe but
your your co-workers are part of a
football team and a point that he makes
that really stood out to me is like when
a tribe goes through a shared trauma as
I think we are right now there's a very
long history of people banding together
and being like look we're all in this
together we're gonna suffer together
we're gonna we're gonna find a solution
together and we're gonna walk out of
this together arm and arm that happens a
lot let me go back to the London Blitz
which I think I think you probably know
more about than I do but I've heard
stories along the similar lines like
everyone was in a terrible situation and
there were their stories and people just
be like look we're in this together
we're gonna rebuild together we're gonna
do this together it's all those stories
to be really inspiring it's not to
minimize the trauma that comes from that
but it's a it's a it's probably
something that is easy to overlook when
you and I are sitting here right now
trying to calm trying to ponder the next
year in front of us it's probably easy
to overlook the benefits in the upside
of what happens when people band
together against a shared enemy I get it
right I got a couple of questions I want
to ask you first about what would be
some indications that the market on a
whole is either getting better or worse
and then I'm gonna we're gonna have one
final question after that I think so let
me as I'm sitting here right now this
will be dated when this podcast comes
out but I'm sitting here right now the
Dow Jones is up 1,700 points you might
think that's great big rebound
maybe we're back I would I would be
cautious about that a massive update is
just as unstable as a massive down day
so what would what would make me think
that the market is is kind of stabilized
it's not that it stops going down it
could still go down but I want to see it
go down by a hundred points not 2,000
points and I want to stop seeing it go
up 1,700 points I want to see it just go
up a hundred points in a day so once
this the the daily percentage movements
become more in line I'll be I'll be more
confident that it's stabilized but
when it's up 1,700 points that to me is
not good news that to me is that to me
is this a sign that no one has any idea
what the hell is going on so that would
be what I'd be looking for is just a but
by the way in the last minute now it's
up 2,000 points yes and that's the thing
we're about to see market closed right
on a Friday evening and then when this
podcast will go out on Monday so you
know on Monday people be watching this
podcast and they might very well might
look and it could be down it could be
done more than that 1,700 right he could
have reversed all of today's games and
more of course I mean it was down 2,000
yesterday now up two thousand a day so
there's net no change it's just what's
happening between his been pure and
utter chaos
okay and final thing we've touched on
Nassim Taleb today and he's got a
concept called anti fragile which is
things which gain from disorder I've got
a couple of suggestions and I wondered
if you had about how people can become
anti fragile during this period perhaps
they're going to be under containment
perhaps they're going to be under some
form of lockdown / house quarantine such
at least at the very least restricted
movement so one of the suggestions which
I've got is to buy a couple of bits of
DIY equipment and maybe some paint and
do some home decorating in that room in
the house that you've been intending and
doing for the last 10 years and now you
finally got it love it I think that's
great I think what I was gonna say along
those lines was hey if you're on
lockdown you got some free time for
whatever great time to listen to some
podcasts read some books that's that's
why I just subscribe in the show notes
below press subscribe here modern wisdom
every Monday every Thursday Morgan
Housel in the building I think most
people I think I run into a lot of
people that say I want to read more I
just don't have time well you you you
might be about to get some time so take
advantage of it yeah exactly well we're
gonna see just how much you actually
want to read more when you do have time
but yeah I couldn't agree more you know
like anti fragile industries podcasting
definitely the episode apart at the
start of this week with Eric D
is now second only to my episode with
you after five days of all-time plays
because obviously people are interested
in that books you know like anything
online Netflix I can't imagine how many
more Netflix things have you seen that
play have you seen that pornhub premium
has given all people in Italy free
access I did I did it is best brilliant
marketing on their part that was that
was a smart decision pornhub is now a
public service disagree I'm not gonna
disagree about that we were talking
earlier on about how I'm having a
girlfriend all that having a partner is
pretty anti fragile because the dating
market is definitely going to suffer
over the next couple of years that's
what no one's talking about Morgan I
need you to start tweeting about the
[ __ ] the the price of Apple and [ __ ] the
Dow Jones I want to know about the
dating market and why it's market yeah
and you're right I think my two prized
assets right now or maybe oh no no I
shouldn't I don't want to frame this as
asset but I was gonna say I'm lucky to
have a spouse right now that I can hang
out with and enjoy a lot of free time
that we didn't have before because we're
kind of on lockdown now so yeah well you
know I travel a lot for work and now of
course all that is canceled so I'm about
to embark on the longest uninterrupted
stretch with my children that I've ever
had which is great right well you might
be great or you might lose your mind so
exactly the other antifragile bits of
advice I've got for you by probably not
second hand or if you do buy second hand
disinfect it a musical instrument you've
been thinking about starting a musical
instrument for ages perhaps that's a way
to do it
definitely books like buy a Kindle like
you know if you've got to prepare for
the absolute worst and potentially
Amazon shipping becomes reduced buy a
Kindle
it's like 79 pounds probably less than a
hundred dollars and you'll just have
essentially unlimited books get an
audible subscription as well Netflix
maybe get an Xbox or a Playstation or
something like that
Amazon Prime for movies you know a
kettlebell a kettlebell a couple of
resistance bands and a couple of cheap
dumbbells from anywhere and that's you
you know like what else do you need
I don't know what else you need that's
me happy I'd be happy living like
intellectual health you got your
physical health what more do you want
I couldn't agree more man look Morgan I
am a genuinely genuine you don't want to
have to speak to you again until your
book comes out because if we do it
because there's another financial crisis
I'll try not to take that as an that's
all but it sounds good it's been so good
twitter.com slash Morgan Housel
H oh you SEL will be linked in the show
notes below I implore you to go and
follow Morgan for some good updates
about what's going on with the market
final thing where would you suggest
people go Morgan for a bit of news if
they want some accurate sort of non
sensationalist news with regards to the
current state of the financial market
and economics is there any way that
you'd suggest that they go that's a
great question I don't know if I have a
good answer other than I think you can
you can tell who's being sensational and
who's not very quickly and it's the I I
don't I don't know if I have a good
answer for that just there's some people
who I follow on Twitter and some of them
seem to be taking a rational stance that
some of them seem to be just
hyperventilating but you know there's a
very good dashboard put out by Johns
Hopkins I believe that just has a world
tally of coronavirus known known carrier
carriers deaths recoveries where they
are a map of the world there's a really
good dashboard to follow just to kind of
track the progress of what's going on
that's really interesting awesome Morgan
thank you so much man I really
appreciate it
everything that we've spoken about
linked in the show notes below you know
what to do like share and subscribe if
you've got any questions feel free to
hustle Morgan on Twitter or me wherever
you follow me Morgan thanks man
this is been fun thank you
[Music]
you